so as we get into our discussion about
the house of M what we're going to be
doing here is we're going to be jumping
back to the old way in which I used to
discuss videos i snotted say we're going
to have this cascading kelley book
panels or anything but we're going to go
very in-depth into the house of M here
and the reason why is because the House
of M was a pivotal story for the mutant
community in the 2000s this was the
mutant community's version of civil war
not in the sense that they were fighting
among each other but in the sense that
this was the story that had basically I
guess maybe changed everything for the
mutant community now the reason behind
why the house of Emma had come around is
because in the year 2000 Joe Quesada who
was previously an artist had stepped
into the role of editor-in-chief from
Marvel Comics and in an interview in
2005 with ICV to what Joe Quesada had
said was that there were basically too
many mutants that what had made the
mutant so unique and so easy to maybe
relate to was the fact that they were a
very small group of people who were
being oppressed by society at large and
so people could identify with this
aspect they could look at this and they
could feel for these characters but now
in 2005 there were just so many mutants
and in truth the term mutant had become
a scapegoat if there was a situation
whereby writers needed someone with some
kind of a power they could just chalk
them up and say they were mutants and it
had really become I guess maybe gotten
to this place where it wasn't what it
should have been that somehow if he can
to deviate away from his initial
intention and so what Joe casada did is
he came along and just told Marvel to
stop and he wiped the slate clean he
said we're going to basically redo
everything when it comes to the mutant
population and explicitly he had stated
again I guess sourcing back to this
interview that he didn't really have any
intention as far as he was
editor-in-chief to bring me this back to
the previous population that is to say
after the events of house of M mutants
were going to stay as a very very small
number and then maybe even incrementally
increase their ranks which is exactly
what we saw following the events of the
house of M but as we get into this story
as we pick up with Part 1 what we find
here is that we join Wanda Maximoff
and one a maksimov has given birth to
twins and what we see is a dr. strange
is congratulating are congratulating her
on the fact that she's given birth to
twins and I would like you to take a
very particular notice of this what's
basically happening is that the
character is she surrounded by wonder
man dr. strange magneto or Quicksilver
we really can't tell from this
perspective and especially the vision
these characters have their own
personalities they have their own
sentience they have their own ideologies
and in fact when we see that the vision
congratulate her he congratulate her in
the exact same way that a father would
now one thing to keep in mind is that
these characters are maybe caricatures
or a reflection of how she perceived her
life should have been but the fact
remains that these are characters that
have their own ideologies and this is
very important as we go forward with the
House of M because what we're going to
see is that when Scarlet Witch works
reality when she changes everything it's
not as though people are going to be
puppets for her whim it's not as though
it's going to be a reflection of the
crooked world storyline of Mad Jim
Jasper's this is going to be a story
whereby everybody's leading a totally
separate life and so what we do is we
continue with this as we see that the
Charles Xavier appears and Charles
Xavier tells her she has to set the
world back that she has no children and
that there's no one in this room but but
Charles Xavier and the Scarlet Witch
herself now in truth Charles Xavier is
probably lying here he's probably lying
to her and the reason why we know that
is because again the Scarlet Witch can
warp reality we saw with a Kree warship
the Kree battleship had appeared and
people had died because of that it
wasn't a mass hallucination it was
something that was being witnessed by
people but didn't actually exist those
things were really taking place and so
this leads us to believe that Charles
Xavier is duping her here that he's
somehow doing what he can to try to get
her to believe that this is actually an
illusion that this isn't really
happening and so we see that the Scarlet
Witch really begins to demonstrate just
how far gone she is just how psychotic
she is and the fact that she's lost her
mind
when she's absolutely convinced that
these children are real when she's
absolutely convinced that everything is
going on it's going on in this moment is
real and in fact we see the vision
comment and tell Charles Xavier not to
speak to his wife that way
demonstrating that the vision has his
own concepts here his own ideologies and
so again as both Wanda Maximoff and
Charles Xavier get into an argument and
they continue to yell back and forth the
Charles Xavier seems to become maybe
overcome himself with that with regards
to this particular scenario and again
what this does is tell us just how
powerful the Scarlet Witch is the fact
that Charles Xavier with all his vast
abilities as having a very difficult
time piercing this veil of reality
altering the she's basically created and
using every ounce of the power that he
has to effectively get her to set things
right is really taking its toll here and
so we eventually see that a Scarlet
Witch acquiesce is and everything seems
to shatter and so what we see here is
that Charles Xavier becomes comforting
The Scarlet Witch and again the Scarlet
Witch is insanity becomes prevalent here
in the sense that she believes where she
really thinks that what's happened is
really what's going on that in fact as
she had that because of her actions she
had killed the Avengers that because of
her actions she had killed the vision
now the vision is a very interesting
subject with regards to Avengers
disassembled and the house of him event
and the reason why is because of course
during the events of Avengers
disassembled we have seen that the
vision had died but the question is that
we don't know whether or not that vision
died as a result of the actions of
Scarlet Witch that is to say he began
spewing out all these different versions
of Ultron because of her actions or if
that was something Ultron had I guess
maybe a program that Ultron had
installed and the vision so that if the
Avengers sent out a white call distress
signal that the vision would respond
accordingly that's something that we
don't know but Scotland which seems to
assume where the variable air of the
very at least believed that she is the
reason for this and so again we see
Charles Xavier bleeding from the nose
indicating that he's maybe reached they
reach the realization that the Scarlet
Witch simply cannot be contained here
and so what we do is we switch over to a
Charles Xavier in the early morning or
perhaps the sunset we're not really sure
but he's speaking with Magneto and
magneto says that he had heard some
screaming in the night on what Charles
says is that this is really a
circumstance everything that's going on
is something that just can't be
controlled here that there's basically I
guess events unfolding in such a way to
where every time the Scarlet Witch uses
her powers every time she alters reality
she loses her grasp on reality
moreso than that she seems to actually
be maybe be getting more adept or
beginning maybe getting more powerful
every time she uses her abilities to the
point where Charles Xavier really can't
keep her contained there really isn't
anything he can do and so what are you
done is he it basically psychically
maybe induced to sleep he basically
tricked her mana into believing that it
was time for her to go to sleep but what
magneto says here is that they can't
keep doing this they can't keep using
tranquilizers and they can't keep
tricking her mind into going to sleep
because it's simply inhumane but again
Charles says that there really wasn't
anything that he can do here there
really isn't anything that he can do on
his own he's not really sure what to do
and so what happens is we ultimately
switch to to Manhattan to New York and
we see that as things are progressing
that Wonder Man that Carol Danvers that
other members are beginning to file
their way to Avengers mansion now keep
in mind again this is after the events
of Avengers disassembled and so stark
tower is maybe the residence to the
Avengers so to speak I guess what's left
of them where people might loosely call
themselves Avengers but the fact remains
that under this particular circumstance
everybody's meeting up in this one
particular location and what we find is
that once he actually actually arrived
inside of stark tower after the Avengers
do they're greeted by by a multitude of
superheroes by the combined forces of
the Avengers as well as Doctor Strange
Robert Reynolds the century Charles
Xavier and Charles tells them that for
the most part they're trying to figure
out what to do here that they need to
discuss the fate of one maximov
indicating to us the Charles Xavier is
toying with the possibility of the fact
that one a Maximoff may very well have
to die here in order to preserve their
universe and so what we do is we switch
back to to wanna match them off to
Scarlet Witch as she's a meeting with
Quicksilver and of course she's sleeping
at this point on she's unconscious
and what Quicksilver is doing is
basically just looking at her just
reconciling over the the knowledge that
he's learned the information that
indicates to him is least as far as he
was able to overhear from Charles Xavier
conversation that the intention of the
Avengers and the x-men is to kill the
Scarlet Witch and in fact he tells this
to magneto he tells Magnus that they're
going to kill his daughter and Magneto
seems a little surprised by this but
even then he doesn't really seem that
concerned and when quick discover begins
to freak out when he begins to I guess
should be
I shall add magneto magneto asked the
question what is he a Capote what's he
supposed to do what is it that he could
do here there really isn't anything he
can do to not only stop the powers of
the Scarlet Witch but to also keep the
Avengers or the x-men from killing her
because in reality and the back of
Magneto's mind I'm willing to wager he
feels there's no other choice here that
her power simply just grown beyond her
ability to control even moreso than that
it's grown beyond the ability for her
sanity to maintain and so she's a danger
not just to this reality but possibly
other realities and so again we see that
that a Quicksilver begins to succumb to
is anguish here and maybe magneto seems
to do the same but what happens is
Quicksilver leaves and magneto leaves
his daughter along with him and so again
what we do is we switch back to Charles
Xavier to the Avengers and the x-men and
we see them entertaining this idea we
see them talking about this idea but of
course as we would expect the ideas
really split down the middle there are
some people like spider-man and Cyclops
and Captain America who say this doesn't
need to happen that she's not some kind
of a dog she's not an animal that has
rabies you can just put down that she's
a human but what's also really splitting
the crowd here is that Scarlet Witch was
them that was an Avenger at one point in
time but she's also a mutant and so the
idea here is that the x-men should
handle this in-house but again Captain
America says as she was an Avenger and
that should be handled by the Avengers
and so again we see that as various
people are beginning to argue as various
people are beginning to to debate here
and ultimately the group comes to the
conclusion that at the very least even
if they're not going to decide right
then and there they should kill her that
they should travel to Genosha and at the
very least talk to her directly and so
what happens here is the group bands
together and they leave and they travel
to Genosha but one thing to keep in mind
here is that all this is after Grant
Morrison's run of the x-men and so
Cassandra Nova has already wiped out 16
million mutants that were currently
housed in Genosha and so as a result
Genosha is a total war zone and so what
we find is that when the Avengers and
the x-men arrive Edward Wanda Maximoff
is supposed to be that one of maximal is
gone that she's completely vanished that
we'll find out at the end of the story
exactly what had taken place that had
led to this circumstance and led to the
entire events as they unfolded in the
House of M but the immediate reaction of
the Avengers and the x-men
that they need to find her and so what
they do is they start to fan out they
start to look around then suddenly they
realize that Charles Xavier is gone that
he simply just vanished and they don't
really know how it was that this has
happened and so the first thing I guess
their first goal here is to find a way
to locate Charles Xavier ziz to find
where Charles Xavier is and then as soon
as they find him to get out of there and
then after that they'll figure out some
way to to deal with the Scarlet Witch
but what we also see here is a doctor
strange is I guess analyzing the mystic
patterns and he's not finding any trace
of Wanda Maximoff but as the group
continues as they travel they eventually
find to where they believe one a
maksimov is now so now Emma Frost here
is using her telepathic powers to locate
one to match them off but again we see
that various other individuals Tony
Stark using its infrared sensors and
Doctor Strange are unable to identify
her being there of course with Tony
Stark using its infrared sensors he
can't see any body heat and and dr.
strange saying that whenever one a
maksimov uses her powers it leaves a
trace of source or at least some kind of
magical indicator that he can recognize
but there's no recognition of her being
here being anywhere in the vicinity and
so again as the group is continuing to
traverse around as they're continuing to
investigate we ultimately see that
various people start disappearing in
sequence ultimately leaving spider-man
as the sole person here and so what
happens as this comic begins to come to
a close is that we pick up with
spider-man as everything begins to turn
white and then when everything seems to
resettle itself we pick up with Peter
Parker as he wakes up to a crying baby
and Peter Parker's told by some
unidentified woman that it's Peters turn
indicating that it's most likely his
turn to I check on the baby and make
sure everything's okay and what we see
is that in a picture next to Peter
Parker's bedside table is Peter Parker
who is apparently married to Gwen Stacy
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly